mauro
e quella e anita nella labbra e gli è
rimasta in pausa
tutti benvenuti solidità oggi video un
po diverso dal solito perché faremo a
grandissima richiesta no pausa challenge
ma la faremo per 24 ore anzi forse anche
più di 24 ore fa se 48 forse 72 perché
siamo in vacanza e abbiamo deciso di
fare la pausa cialente questa vacanza ci
rovineremo la vacanza o board stima sarà
super divertente
facciamo vedere dove siamo è stato
vedere l'africa tutta la destra provate
a indovinare in che città stiamo un po
difficile da dominare però vediamo
magari qualcuno indovina comunque
iniziamo allora qua l'entrata i colori
sono bellissimi giallo per celeste wow
qua c'è la caffettiera e the year ha
visto che la foca avendo quasi il bagno
dopo che lo possiamo vedere meglio
perché il bagno la cosa più fila di
questa stanza poi quasi il letto durante
questo lampadario che strano a 123 quota
56 luci quasi uno specchio gigantesco
già guarda giochi spengo dati spendono
come si fa a spegnere a vita ma quando
non è il nostro telecom ma se una tv
dietro allo specchietto perché vedevo
una luce blu strane pensavo qualcuno si
sta spiando e cielo diventa nascosta
nello specchio poi la cosa più bella qua
e là vista centrone gigante e abbiamo la
vista nel centro della città
bellissimo promod indovinare non
esattamente in che ci tassiamo perché un
po difficile in che nazione siamo
secondo voi prima di dirvelo ovvero
quanto stiamo in alto prima di dirvelo
vi faccio vedere il bagno che fighissimo
allora cosa darei per avere un bagno
così a casa allora abbiamo due lavandini
tondi
poi uno specchio triplo enorme
poi c'è traversi nasconde c'è una cosa e
questo shampoo e gel da bagno ok ma
senza dentale ap quattro linee
ecco cosa potete capire dove stiamo
perché c'è scritto bene che vuol dire
pettine in spagnolo quindi se siamo in
spagna precisamente siamo a granada per
fare questo è un hotel bio ecologico
quindi tutte le cose sono bio ed
ecologiche e il ristorante ufficiale del
modello emiliano quindi potete già
capire perché ho scelto questo punto poi
equazione un altro stati dentale
ovviamente perché siamo in due
ma guardate questa doccia non so se si
vede perché sia riflesso comunque qua ci
sono gli accappatoi qua ci sono gli
asciugamani con le ciabattine allora
questa doccia
praticamente ci puoi camminare dentro e
super spaziosa aspetta che prodotta le
quattro team
ecco le norme è enorme e mi ha detto
dobbiamo come che paghiamo tutto una
volta che sentiamo quasi solo un vetro
di protezione terzo ma già facendo
casino brutto l'iniziativa sentito
comunque cosa ne pensate di questa falsa
a me piace tantissimo soprattutto il
bagno
allora stavo cercando una cosa che cosa
ho fame aspetta ancora non abbiamo
mangiato si muove non rigotti non
abbiamo ancora mangiato ma eccolo niente
mattino mai vissuto nuovo ea provare il
phon o la doccia e vorrebbero mangiare 1
st con andrea letto ma ora devi rimanere
così in equilibrio io vado a mangiare
nel frattempo ciao ciao ciao
poverino è già pentito di avere cose far
arrivare questo challenge vero però devo
mangiare primo giorno che i ora andiamo
a mangiare allora ecco qua ribatti
abbiamo stretto abbiamo presto del sushi
decano bellissimo non mi ricordi ingrid
in che ha dentro però sembra bellissimo
poi una punta ball si può che paul si
chiama
avvocato prima cosa che penso sia punta
mi sembra tutto buoni primo un buon
appetito
e anche un susco
e ora di merenda siamo tornati nascosto
e guardate un po vita ne conta che
inizia
ci fu poi abbiamo preso una rete al
cioccolato e poi una smoothie al
cioccolato lo stesso suonato macadamia
il latte di cocco sempre tutto legale e
vitale pensa che si mangerà assaggiamo
passeggia messaggio non è troppo dolce
macadamia mi mangio tutto il sistema di
mangiare e ma non puoi mangiare così
tanto non vuole mangiare tutto palla
[Musica]
poverino
[Risate]
buono
si no
sblocco senti a me questa cosa della
causa la mia vita adesso per la pausa
pranzo
[Applauso]
o
devo dire telefono
da tempo
a torino non si sblocca mimino
maledetto meloni che ho tanti amici sono
buono te ne voglio lasciare metà lotto e
questo me lo prendo io ha detto che
questa sia bello abbiamo scoperto delle
scale fantasma o perché guardate queste
scale
ciao a tutti ma non c'è niente ci sono
le scale ma non c'è niente sono delle
scale per i nani delle scale per dei
folletti magari vivono dei folletti li
guardate questo corridoio inquietante lo
stesso ma è una lampada al contrario
buongiorno colazione abbiamo sempre nel
ristorante vegano con le piante sopra e
abbiamo queste non sono appunto perché
vengano mai tofu con spinaci
informazioni cannes
a me invece italia ha preso lo stesso
letto con avvocato e sembra buonissimo e
ora abita nello lascio così nel
frattempo vi mando tutto
volete la faccia disperata siamo
all'alhambra e siamo nei giardini ed è
una figata perché sembra il labirinto di
harry potter
andiamo assieme ad essere dentro il
labirinto
pausa quindi dicevamo stiamo vedendo
stiamo vedendo tutti i giardini
dell'alhambra e sembra un labirinto
[Musica]
pausa come è stato bello essere pausa
televisiva tra l'altro la fede destrezza
liberavano persone mi critichi stando
alla stessa maniera
non c'è una bellissima giornata per ogni
bene andiamo a vedere quella fontana lì
che a lei la fontana del vaglio di
mirtilla malcontenta che accede alla
camera dei segreti è vero
[Applauso]
quindi è enorme perché dentro lo chiama
nascondino si sente che non ha scandito
io volo i quali è vero
[Applauso]
da che parte state non lo so ma cosa che
ti pago so qui paura e io me ne vado
ciao
e triste ciao io mi voglio divertire
allora vediamo tutte le vostre belle
fontanin la fontanina da dietro
che bello
[Applauso]
andiamo recuperare anima che poverina è
rimasta lì è entrato a segnare scappata
via spa versata poiché pian pausa e ieri
[Applauso]
vivo
cerchiamo la colpa tremaghi la coppa tre
mani ma chi ci sono non ti ricordi
no qui non voglio tornare a casa
aspetta aspetta in un'idea per farli
rimanere qui a cercare arida la mettiamo
in pausa abbiamo tanta tanta tanta tanta
tanta tanta tanta
[Musica]
adesso mette in pausa volta attraverso
una magari per sbaglio
[Musica]
cosa ti ho trovata in questa posizione
così poco confortevole ti posso lasciare
così ma secondo me sì tipo sociale così
vabbè io vado taogd poveri nani da
playboy basa clienti devi comportare
così ballet con me altrimenti io non ti
applauso più
e capita
no io non mi fido di te che la faccetta
così ho paura che non mi mise queste il
telecomando e comincia a mettermi pausa
a me vedeva niente da fare
ciao ok allora duca riprendiamo con il
giro nella l'ambra nei giardini
dell'alhambra questo è l'orto
dell'alhambra queste sono le muraglie
delle labbra e quella e anita nella
labbra che è rimasta in pausa
ciao ciao se ti han pausa promette di
essere buona con me di non mettervi in
pausa di non rubarmi il telecomando di
farmi mangiare tutto quello che voglio
stai dicendo sì e con la testa lei ha
praticamente non è vero ma ci credo non
ci credo
i ragazzi sono in bagno allora ho
escogitato sanità in praticamente
siccome non voi voglio assolutamente
vincere io questa questa challenge e
andrò a fare un piccolo scherzetto
dovrò mettere queste cosette quindi la
tira nella doccia attirerò con una scusa
e poi la tua compagna re tutta via
d'angolo e così in italia per andare a
prendere il cosa dell'acqua e qui per
aprirlo e lei si pagherà tutto l'amore è
trovato quel nuovo col nuovo shampoo che
hanno messo e non è uno shampoo
bagnoschiuma ha ammesso oggi la donna
dalla polizia
potevi troppo sentire il suo motore
meraviglioso e poi sempre più si è
diverso questo qui praticamente c'è un
tubetto dorato cioè no il tubetto di
argento però c'è il bordino dorato
quindi più pregiato direi lo devi troppo
sentire tu guarda non si si si è
speciale droga
ciao anno con l'obiettivo già in doccia
praticamente la loro visione in doccia
no no è quello è quello che sta giù lì
dentro
[Musica]
di fronte allora tu sai perché hai paura
perché qua sopra c'è la doccia il rain
forest credo si chiami io l'ho trovata
questa mattina ed è fantastica scritto
bella dovresti provare pure tu ma da
vestita ora io sono di qua adesso e ti
dico prometti che vi farei mangiare
tutto quello che voglio e non mi rompe
rai
dai se me lo permetti io non ti apro
l'acqua adesso mentre sei pausa tollo
provetti bene ammettilo no ma tra
l'altro non sei proprio completamente
sotto quindi magari ti potrei amp a
usare per un secondo e poi riposare
nonno secondo me tu sei troppo furba
guarda guarda quella faccia leader da
persona troppo furba che non mi
permetterebbe neanche di pensare che già
mi starebbe già con le mie con le mani
sul mio collo pronta a struggle armi non
ho io non mi fido quindi di bagno per
metà quindi non promette
[Musica]
no possono valutare tutto quello che
voglio
[Musica]
ma non si fa e quello troppo ti devi
impegnare di più io scappo ciao
finalmente rilasciata di sotto la roccia
quindi io adesso mi metto che ti guardo
la mia tv come si accende la tv agenti
che tv line succede alla tv si chiama si
accende la televisione ora rimarrei così
tutta la notte io lascerò davanti ad
adro attirare detto niente così voi
qualcuno baciata è sbagliato tutto
avvertito nei cappelli cavolo bravo ora
mi mangia tutto ora mi mangio tutto ei
master
aspetta un attimo mi hai rotto hai rotto
il gioco è rotto la challenge perché io
avevo lasciato in pausa li mantengo
sbloccato ero venuto qui a vedere la tv
e tu hai lasciato tutto così quindi vuol
dire che hai perso perché è interrotto
la pausa in cui ti avevo messo ma ma non
potevo rimanere un tradizioni lì tutta
la rosa con il questi mi dispiace quindi
ho vinto io molto basta e quindi mi
faccio così
ok allora dotale ha vinto questa
challenge effettivamente perché io ho
rotto la pausa perché non mi volevo
infradicia re completamente non so se si
rivede non so se si capisse ma il
vestito e fradicio tra l'altro qua alla
finestra ci sarà qualcuno che si stava
guardando e che ha pensato ma questi
sono pazzi cosa stanno facendo una
ciabatta una miccia ripara la sua
maggiore il genitore da più brutta di
tutti pure aggregati bene ma che tutti
un po bagnarono indagini commenti come
mi dovrei vendicare se volete che
rifacciamo la pausa challenge per 24 ore
però il modo di vendicarmi ho vitale sì
è vero ho vinto perché io ho dovuto
togliere lo porto metterci nei commenti
come dovrei dedicarli scriveteci che
altri challenger dobbiamo fare così
troverò il modo di vendicarsi
oppure bisogna semplicemente accettare
di aver perso e gli occhi domenica
prossima volta quindi lasciate un bel
like e se questo video dice 10.000 live
vetrate la vendetta
sconsigliati silenzio da fare nei
commenti ora vi lasciamo qua 4 quadrati
su cui clicca per vedere le nostre altre
channel i nostri altri video divertenti
cliccate su quella che preferite buona
visione
ciao ora un simbolo che vitale se ne
pentirà